le retour de la Star Academy
on reste dans l'erreur alors on en parle
regardez on a un dogue dessus on va voir
toutes les infos on vous dit tout tout
très honnête c'est le produit Siri m'a
dit que tu peux dire ce que tu veux moi
je le sens pas tellement mais je peux
indiquer le sud regardez
dans une semaine les portes du château
de la Star Academy vont rouvrir un seul
réalisera son rêve devenir star après 14
ans d'absence sur TF1 l'école de chant
la plus prisée de France va accueillir
ces tous nouveaux académiciens Enola la
partie de la nouvelle promotion de la
Star Ac bientôt sur TF1 ils seront très
au total à intégrer l'aventure samedi
soir côté animation pas de changement
c'est Nikos Aliagas qui sera aux
commandes de ce grand retour c'est que
tout a commencé un bac il y a pas Nico
c'est le château de Dammarie-les-Lys
refait à neuf tout va changer nouveau
prof nouveau plateau mais aussi nouveau
directeur essayez d'apporter à chacun
d'entre eux ce dont ils ont besoin pour
devenir meilleur Michael le fils de
Jean-Jacques Goldman dirigera cette
nouvelle promo et si les stars ont fait
le succès de la Star Ac soir welcome
Star Academy on parle déjà d'une
chanteuse internationale comme marraine
de la saison j'ai lu le nom de Céline
Dion sur les réseaux est-ce que c'est
elle j'ai lu aussi si l'engouement
autour de la Star Academy semble bel et
bien réel TF1 s'est lancé un véritable
Paris en relançant cette émission culte
des années 2000 alors croyez-vous au
grand autour de la Star Ac
vous savez
pour moi déjà
la star qui est morte quand j'ai arrêté
de l'animé c'est toi qui l'a tué
[Rires]
toutes les grandes années c'était TF1
NRJ12 et donc je l'avais animé ça fait
un mur personne ne le sait
voilà c'est comme ça c'est toujours au
bon moment le timing alors là justement
durée de l'émission qui alors vous dit
qui est qui croit qui croit pas qui
croit le petit Maxime qui y croit déjà
durer l'émission est-ce que tu sais
c'est combien de temps bien sûr cette
prime pourquoi c'est aussi short parce
que il y a la Coupe du monde donc ils
ont voulu faire un truc hyper condensé
pour une formation en accéléré avec le
même principe une quotidienne un peu
plus longue de 45 minutes sans plateau
c'est un pari éditorial c'est aussi
parce que ils essaient d'être dans la
case de famille nombreuse
samedi
tout en images
la quotidienne quotidienne
le samedi 17h 17h20 mais non on ne sera
pas encore nous commenter
sur parrain qui sont par un marraine
est-ce que quelque chose non non bébé
entre le parrain entre le directeur de
la
il y a une semaine ils étaient à 5 % de
terminer la négociation ça sera un
parrain ou une marraine international
concernant les invités spéciaux il y
aura du Jenifer il y aura évidemment
toutes les stars françaises parce que
aujourd'hui la prod elle est saine en
deux en bémol qui a le format et des MLS
TV Mathieu Vergnes les [ __ ] entre
autres avec un gros réseau de
programmation d'artistes donc c'est la
raison pour la guerre il y a aussi on va
casser la vérité pour le moment
effectivement sur Paramètres on serait
sur du Céline Dion euh voilà et en
parrain voilà il y a Kylie Minogue aussi
qui rentre dedans mais pour l'instant
c'est des négociations pour l'instant
ils les auraient pas moi masterakama je
vous rappelle que energy 12 on leur a
fait bonjour à taver un écran salut
Céline elle était au Canada
ça pour l'instant on en est là ils vont
nous faire une énergie Music Awards avec
nous ce soir nous allons faire un
message pendant deux heures elle va
arriver à acheter sur les fêtes là
normalement ça va être plus à chier non
le seul truc mais c'est la vérité qu'on
se le dise qu'on se connaît très bonne
en imitation il n'y croit pas pourquoi
parce que vous avez vu comment c'est
court ils font ils font cette prime donc
même ils croient pas parce que si ça
marche sur une saison 2 sur les anciens
une mise tout sur les anciens donc
toutes les semaines vous allez avoir
tous les dimanches des anciens qui vont
venir dîner avec un simple expliqué
effectivement il y aura le dimanche le
dîner du dimanche soir où les nouveaux
dîneront avec des anciennes gloire qui
ne sont pas devenues et qui leur
expliqueront bah comment on devient
marcher sauf que j'ai entendu super
merci météorite le conseil
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est pas impensable qu'on
puisse voir Céline Dion en sachant que
le directeur de la Star Academy va être
le fils de Jean-Jacques Goldman et
Jean-Jacques Goldman celui qui a écrit
tous les titres de Céline Dion
sauf que tu oublies qu'on a une voyante
pas de bonnes infos sur Céline Dion
est-ce que je peux vous dire moi en
revanche sur Céline Dion parce que j'ai
pas les infos sur tout mais vous savez
qu'on avait eu Jacky Lombard dans cette
émission pour les téléspectateurs qui
nous regardent qui est vraiment la
productrice de tous les artistes
internationaux Elton John Pink Floyd et
je l'ai au téléphone il y a une semaine
elle me dit pour le moment Céline Dion
je reconnais que voilà tout est bouche
tout est bloqué pour le moment on annule
pas mais on ne confirme pas elle bouge
pas pour le moment donc si elle bouge
pas elle bouge pas qui veut parler oui
pardon
du dimanche alors moi j'étais pas du
tout je pensais que ça marcherait pas du
tout je reconnais que comme Maxime après
avoir assisté à la conférence et les
avoir entendus les uns les autres je
suis un peu plus convaincu pas sur la
diffusion du dimanche soir je pense que
c'est trop vraiment casse-gueule en
revanche moi si m’intéresse le plus
souvent la diffusion en direct et en
direct oui samedi soir en direct
il y a un truc qui m'intéresse beaucoup
c'est qu'il y a 20 ans quand il disait
ou 13 candidats vous allez être intégrer
et tout et tout il disait oh je suis
content tout le monde va me voir et tout
là ils disent ah mais oui mais alors je
vais être influenceur je m'apporter ça à
une mycose je leur dis NON NON et oh ça
la règle n'a pas changé vous êtes sans
portable sans rien en bas et toujours et
là il y a un truc et là j'ai pas vous
faire mon Cyril qui fait son Danse avec
les stars mais quand même pour ceux qui
les connaissent je vous annonce donc les
profs
Adeline tonutti Auchan à Nice Marchal à
la danse pierre de boirer au théâtre
leur ballon en expression
Aria crescendo pour le yoga et là comme
je vous ai dit on va quand même dire des
choses bien quand même parce que bon euh
par exemple dans les profs de de ton
prof de danse c'est
c'est c'est c'est ça mais Yanis Marshall
qui a fait peur
on l'avait reçu dans le mag à l'époque
c'est celui qui a démocratisé la danse
en talon avec les garçons incroyable
absolument
avec des escargots il est beau ah bah
c'est bien ça c'est très très bien on
fait toujours la même erreur il a
commencé la star le grand public ne la
connaissait pas tout le monde est né
voilà alors tous ces programmes quand
ils ont commencé ils étaient pas connu
et après quand tu es une forte
personnalité elle se dégage c'est pareil
pour Chris markers
de quelques personnes des anciennes Star
Ac qui seront là donc il y a carrément
charme qui était là saison 4
comment elle présente l'after dans le
présentateur ça fera la Karine Ferri
du retour au château avec Nico sans
plateau et elle en duplex et en direct
dans le
buste
qu'on a noté avec Maxime parce qu'elle
avait dit qu'elle était suggérer qu'elle
était représentatrice Nikos là très
gentiment très finement trip
diplomatiquement rappeler qu'elle sera
dans le bus et lui un animateur voilà
voilà
aucune co-animation qui marche les gens
peuvent pas stocker à qui on fait croire
ça quand même on va pardon nous c'était
bien
oui c'était bien mais on connaît pas
alors vous savez qu'à la base ça devait
être carré Karine Ferri qui devait être
à la base de karimacha ouais la pauvre
ça pue pour elle là-bas
non à la base elle devait co-animer avec
les causes sauf qu'elle a fait il y a
pas très longtemps une interview pour
faire un peu flipper TF1 en disant je ne
ferme pas la porte etc mais j'ai eu
d'autres propositions d'accord France
Télévisions ce qui est complètement faux
et du coup alors Jennifer nous a fait
c'est génial j'avais fait ce qu'a fait
une Christophe Dechavanne dans avec Léa
Salamé quelle époque je veux pas être
chroniqueur mais en même temps je peux
pas être invité alors je suis comment ça
s'appelle
invité permanent qui m'a envoyé un petit
texto très désagréable Christophe
Dechavanne parce qu'il paraît qu'on dit
pas du bien de lui donc je suis vraiment
désolé d'être sincère et donc il a
envoyé à Jennifer sera évidemment
présente mais elle aura un traitement à
part comme elle a dit voilà Lucie
Bernard Denis
chirurgie esthétique
non non non non il y en a un qui l'a
fait il faut dire qu'il est au fond de
la scène il y a un caillou ici il sait
pas jeter tout seul non non il y aura
après le spécial consacré à Grégory
Lemarchal voilà donc écoutez personne
parle de l'oseille en fait parce que
pendant des années le gagnant gagné 1
million et un contrat cette année 60 000
c'est pas la même donne c'est toujours
un million alors dernière info d'Alien
on arrête alors moi je pense que tout le
monde se méprend sur l'arrivée de cette
émission qui à mon sens va être un vrai
carton je pense que c'est attendu ça
reste une émission culte en tout cas j'y
crois personnellement je crois très fort
ça nous fait du bien de revoir des
émissions qu'on a regardé comme ça quand
on était plus jeune donc moi je suis
pour ça c'est le premier point et le
second point c'est que ils ont eu
l'intelligence et je salue le génie de
toute l'équipe et de Mathieu Vergne que
c'est que je salue d'avoir distillé au
compte-goutte d'avoir distillé au
compte-goutte les infos donc on est tous
en train de raconter nos vies depuis
tout à l'heure mais je vous assure que
vous allez avoir de très très belles
surprises ça vouloir spoiler rien du
tout
c'est celui qui est le patron qui va
s'occuper de la de la grande programme
nation tu dis avec Mathieu Verne toi
c'est un ami dans l'ami c'est pas le
mari d'Ophélie meunier si tout à fait
oui
très bien Christophe et on finit et
juste une petite question je sais pas
combien coûtait un prime à l'époque de
Star Academy mais je pense pas qu'ils
mettent autant cette année pour le
produire ah bah non bah non non non bah
non mais ça on te confirme avec le lot
même en tant qu'animation et tout ça
c'est plus les mêmes du carton pâtes et
on passe à autre chose